[Music]
we have a great show for you today we're
going to get right to our first couple
of topics because we have a very
important guest today Benjamin Hall will
join us later right here at the table to
share his incredible Story of Survival
nearly a year to the day since a
devastating blast in Ukraine almost took
his life but first Democrats getting
slammed for attacking the Twitter files
journalists in an explosive hearing
liberals claim to love freedom of the
press unless it's something that makes
them look bad Democrats ripping the
reporters who broke the story exposing
how Twitter worked with the feds to
silence free speech
Elon Musk spoon fed you his
cherry-picked information which you must
have suspected promotes a slanted
viewpoint or at the very least generates
another right-wing conspiracy theory is
it true that you have profited since you
were received you were this recipient of
the Twitter files you've made money
that's probably a wash honestly nope
you've you have made money that you did
not have before correct but I've also
spent money that I didn't know okay
attention is a powerful drug eyeballs
money prominence attention all of it
points to problems with accuracy and
credibility
the attacks going even further Dems also
tried to intimidate and demand to know
the source of the Twitter files
this isn't just a matter of what data
was given to these so-called journalists
before us now ranking member Plaskett
um I'm not a so-called journalist I've
won the national magazine award the I
have stone award for independent
journalism and I've written 10 books
including four New York Times New York
Times bestsellers you consider Mr must
to be the direct source of all this no
now you're you're trying to get me to
say that he is the source I I I can't
answer your question if you're telling
me you can't answer because it's your
Source well then Dad the only logical
conclusion is that he is in fact your
Source well you're free to conclude that
you know it is amazing Dana instead of
thanking them for what we all know was a
coordinated effort by the government to
influence social media cut back freedom
of the press for First Amendment speech
of everyone on social media they're
trying to say that these guys were only
into the money and they tried to find
out the source I mean this is stunning
it was pretty shocking I mean whatever
happened to the Democrats who defended
the First Amendment and the reporters
remember during the Trump Administration
there was an army of Democrats who would
defend the fourth estate from any
reporter who is called a bad name and
also there were journalists who were
targeted like that was bad but now you
have these too especially Matt taibi
yeah I've seen bad hearing prep before
I've never seen anything this bad if
your Witnesses are openly laughing at
you because you're so bad at what you do
and you're that unprepared and you have
no idea what you're talking about like
not even knowing who Barry Weiss was
that she's integral to this effort on
the Twitter files and the Congress
people people didn't even know who she
was I think it's a genuine embarrassment
for the house Democrats because they've
always been they always think they're
the younger savvier party and the
congresswoman who doesn't know what a
sub stack is I mean that is pretty
incredible to me for anybody out there
who doesn't know I'm not saying that you
should know but the congresswoman who's
going to question these guys should know
it's basically a way that you can write
an article that you can post yourself so
you can be your own publisher but people
will often pay you for that some of them
are free
Jesse you know what it was as though the
shield law that protects reporters
sources doesn't even exist it's that
they were demanding it right out in the
open who the source is and you know you
have to say to yourself if they're doing
this out in the open in violation of The
Shield law what are they doing behind
the scenes so we know what they're doing
behind the scenes because we exposed it
and they don't care about the corruption
they don't care about the collusion or
the censorship they care that it was
reported they want to know who told you
we were corrupt show me the names so
they're doing this
and they're defending it and that's the
sad part they're not even asking real
questions they're they're they're
they're they're defending the censorship
they're trying to destroy the
credibility of these reporters and any
reporter that would dare report
negatively on the Democratic party
remember the reporters in DC and all
over the country report in lockstep with
the left so these are independent
journalists who exposed left-wing
corruption and they're out under oath
and they're trying to say they're in it
for the money
these guys don't make a lot of money
right they don't and Debbie Wasserman
Schultz of all people made so much money
trading stocks as a member of Congress
how dare she accuse someone else of
being corrupt and these guys are liberal
reporters these guys have like ACLU
credentials they don't have Maga hats on
and they're doing this for power because
remember what was not allowed to be said
judge on social media before the
election couldn't say lab leak you
couldn't say natural immunity you
couldn't say the laptop and now you're
allowed to say all that and they're
panicking because the censorship's the
only really thing that keeps them in
power they can't persuade their policies
are unpopular they just need to hold
power tightly you know um Harold there
was a bill uh that the Democrats voted
on and the Bill had to do with making
sure that they could ban Federal
officials from policing the content of
speech and the Republicans voted to ban
Federal officials from policing the
content of speech and the Democrats
voted against it and their reasoning was
that they should be able to make sure
that people like Russia and China cannot
spread disinformation since when do we
say that we can we can oversee the the
information
first I'm glad Dana's back around the
table hadn't seen you in two weeks I was
yesterday Sandra was great but it's good
good to see everybody two the
um I don't know that bill and I would
agree with if that bill is what you're
saying I do think right but I mean I I
don't I didn't take I didn't look up the
bill uh uh per se nor do I think it's
wrong to try to ensure that China and
Russia don't have a way to try to
influence voters try to influence kids
one of the reasons we're going out to
tick tocks because we think China might
be behind that but I don't disagree with
with the the censorship piece here I I
I'm a believer that if you're going to
have a hearing like this you should be
prepared and if you're going to ask
questions to suggest that they should
not be wasting their time doing this and
you should have questions that they do
that I thought the clips that we showed
were not necessarily favorable towards
members of my party who were there I do
wish that some of the oversight stuff
does also find its way to perhaps
calling uh the Dan and other the
alphabet soup of law enforcement to say
what are we doing at the border to
prevent know coming in what more do you
need what more money do you need I do
hope they will come to some of that at
some point oversight hearings are
designed in many ways judge when I was
in Congress to outline where Behavior
could be better in government uh and
whether when particularly was unethical
or illegal Behavior or money could be
spent differently so I don't I'm not
bothered by them calling their Twitter
files and I do think Matt TV is a
respect as a guy who's well respected
I'd be I would have been curious as to
what made him want to do this and what
did he uncover that he thinks was so
damn job I wouldn't have asked the
questions that were asked there so I
don't disagree with you there okay all
right so uh before you answer Brian do
you sometimes wish that the Republicans
would fight as hard as the Democrats do
I mean everyone knows that what they did
was suppress Free Speech First Amendment
and make sure that that that information
there were meetings with the FBI and DHS
and they could have affected a
presidential election my answer is no
because it's on everything they did was
unethical and if that means fighting
hard unethically forget it that's not to
be fighting hard you got to do it right
every once in a while there's stories
that you just think about non-stop so I
had a chance to meet Matt taibi about a
month ago when this first happened they
interviewed him twice since then had a
chance to really research his background
and this was an unbelievably insulting
hearing and he writes about it today
yeah he said he prepared for it he wrote
about it he said I went there I was kind
of nervous I was prepared to just tell
everyone what was going on because he
walked into a treasure Trove of
information for a journalist not for
Republican and Democrat he found out the
FBI paid Twitter 3.4 million dollars to
take down and respond to everything they
needed to do and they were underpaid by
the amount of communication that took
place he talked about Adam Schiff having
him and his staff Call up asking for
certain things to be taken down covid uh
wear a mask don't wear a mess
ivermectin's bad Ira mechan's good all
this stuff had to be taken down and
shaped according to the Republic the
Democratic narrative and he's willing to
talk about it just on the facts he had
instead they want to attack a guy with
great integrity who couldn't be further
from a conservative in real life in case
you didn't hear it Michael
schellenberger voted for Joe Biden he
ran uh he ran for office he is somebody
that was very much for the green
movement he writes this much of the Hub
of yesterday involved the many
involved this is this if they were
saying when did Elon Musk start beating
your wife he said it was a bizarre
collection display of a whole group of
politicians not understanding some
pretty basic things about how to act
around a journalist this was an absolute
abomination embarrassment and this is
the biggest story that nobody's talking
about yesterday was the exposure time
and they didn't expose anything and my
feeling is there's more to come all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else